yes of course it can I mean we talked
about it earlier with Napoleon where it
goes to your head you lose a sense of
proportion and you start thinking of
yourself as a God and a lot of rappers
have that problem the money comes it
comes too fast and then it goes just as
fast because they don't understand that
a lot of it came by out by a bit of luck
by accident and now once you have
success you got to be careful you know
take a step back and be strategic they
don't know that and they lose it if T's
a very strategic person in life he's
also a human being who has weaknesses
and limitations as well so I think he
will always land on his feet
like a cat in this world because he was
shot and nearly died and he knows a
sense of proportion I'll always have
millions of dollars that's never going
to go away what do I have to worry about
I'm you know I already face death every
day to me seems like I'm on borrowed
time I'm just happy to be alive I'm
making money and I'm ambitious but it
doesn't matter you know you have that
kind of attitude you'll land on your
feet sometimes he's had problems his
records aren't doing so well I don't
know what his new record is doing I
haven't been following it he's dealt
with mistakes he's made but I've seen
him I've seen him time and again he'll
be upset for a day and then next week
he's completely forgotten it and moved
on he'll land on his feet Tiger Woods
you know to play golf on that level I'm
kind of fascinated with it it's going to
be sort of the subject of my next book
I'm not writing about golf but I'm
writing about the mindset of somebody
who is powerful and is able to focus
deeply on something you know playing
golf and running your personal life are
two different skill sets so they don't
necessarily translate one to the other
in fact they can kind of not thing kind
of clash which is what we've seen on the
golf course his boldness his aggression
his strategic genius his attention to
detail and how much he's mastered all
the small parts of golf
it all comes to just channels into this
one
beautiful flow turning into this supreme
DaVinci of golf Tiger Woods but you can
control a game like golf which is a very
uncontrollable game with all of this
practice in this effort and this talent
you can't control your personal life in
the same way and in fact feeling like
you're aggressive and ambitious means he
has to attack a new woman almost like
he's attacking a gusta you know the
Masters and he needs these new
challenges and so the two don't
necessarily mesh well and that's not a
question of something except for a
person's character and how they've
learned their experiences in life you
take someone like a John F Kennedy who
you may or may not revere AI Kevin think
he's a very smart man would have been if
you live longer a great president he
made a law he was having dalliance his
left right and center we only know about
it in hit now if he'd been living in the
Internet age forget about it you know he
Tiger Woods doesn't have that room to
learn and experience and grow in his
character because it's all out there in
the public naked for us to see it's
terrible thing for someone like that so
you know he's probably chastised he's
probably learning that he shouldn't have
married this woman he should have been
single and so did his Wild Oats and now
he's going to do this or whatever he has
to learn to bring those two worlds and
make it something that has that flow
like he has on the golf course any will
he's a great man